you're listening to episode one
of storycast 21 i'm jane secker
on december the 26th 2004 southeast asia
was devastated by a massive tsunami
triggered by an undersea earthquake
among the millions following news
reports around the world
was cristiano ronaldo the portuguese
football star
known to many as one of the greatest
players of all time but less well known
for his role in this remarkable survival
story
this is miracle boy
good morning more than 12 000 people
have been killed by
tidal waves up to 30 feet high across
southern asia
they were triggered by an earthquake
under the indian ocean off the
indonesian island of sumatra the most
powerful quake the world has seen
for 40 years i'm phil hooper and i'm a
cameraman editor
the province of aceh appears to have
been worst affected
but most lines of community bandarachae
is a
small fishing town at the top of
indonesia
and it was the closest place to the
epicentre of the earthquake
eyewitnesses said a wall of water
appeared to simply rise
out of the sea there was no warning in
southern
when the tsunami hit bandarachae
it hit with the fullest force and
completely wiped the town
and the communities for 20 30
40 miles along this this stretch of
shoreline which is washed away
only a handful were rescued and brought
safely ashore
you'd be about a mile away from the sea
and there would be boats when i say
boats i mean fishing boats like trawlers
on top of houses and this is a mile away
from the sea
a lot of what i do if i turn up on your
doorstep
it's not good news this story despite
being in utter devastation
gives us hope that there is always
something good on the horizon
and martin bells my role really was
sort of health and safety organization
security issues
because bandarachi at the time was not
particularly safe
i'd never heard of a tsunami before so i
didn't really know what to expect and
then when we got there it's
completely shocking a huge tidal wave
more than 30 feet high
a mountainous wall of water washed away
all in its immediate path
they were putting the body parts in one
pile but the heads
and another but i guess it started off
as like a rower head but it just
there were so many the busy harbour was
submerged
under a torrent of water they say 200
000 dead people and i can easily believe
that i mean there were
literally dead bodies everywhere
[Music]
and in the end they realized it there
was nobody to come and identify them
because they were all dead
so they they bought those them all up
we were initially i think just sort of
recording and reporting on what they saw
and then
as a sort of days became weeks they were
looking more for stories
well now about i don't know 21 days i
get into into being there
we'd heard that some fishing fleets or
fishing boats
had survived because they were on the
other side of the tsunami so they saw it
coming in from the back end if you like
so we were pushing our way down towards
what would have been the beach
it was phil hooper our cameraman and ian
doverster who was the reporter
we got as far as we could parked up on
this little
knoll that was still i think a couple of
hundred yards maybe from the beach
and the area looked just like the song
as i've seen on many movies it was just
bodies your standing tree
mud as far as you could see i mean it
was desolate right
i was just kind of looking around
thinking nothing out there
then i saw something move i saw it was a
kid
kind of waddling around in in the mud
so i saw in the end i kind of waded over
to him
i was born on the 2nd of may 1997
and i live in banda actually he was
absolutely totally covered in mosquito
bites
and i kind of picked him up and uh
took him over to the group thinking that
you know he'd wandered off you know
lad was wearing the portuguese football
shirt
he would have been around about the same
age as my youngest daughter
the day that you were born very very
thin
you know almost emaciated we are
interesting about
your experience in doverstone would have
kind of been talking through the
translator to find out what his name was
where he came from
had he seen his family what has he been
doing
[Music]
i was eight years old
that morning i was playing football with
my friends
i ran back home and some neighbors
started screaming
saying the sea was rising
[Music]
i ran outside with my mom and my sisters
and my relatives
we managed to get on our small truck
but the waves were too close and it
immediately hit us
i was able to pick up my three-year-old
sister when she was drowning and handed
her to my mother
then a high wave hit us again and i was
unconscious
when i woke up there was no one around
me
i woke up on top of a mattress
when it drowned i was hit by a tree
trunk
which then pushed me to the sea in an
area about three kilometers from my
house
in that place there were a lot of
corpses and i slept among those bodies
i cried from time to time because i was
all alone and remembered my family
he had been basically living on the
beachfront
he had seen his family washed away
he'd obviously then been wrapped up in
the wave and deposited somewhere
but he was trying to make his way back
there
to see if there was any survivors
he was sleeping in amongst bodies
finding floating packets of dried
noodles
and that's what he would be eating for
20 days
all i could think of was my family
i didn't see anyone alive during these
days
i slept on a bed where there were many
bodies
i mean how he managed to sleep in that
environment
with dead bodies thinking his family had
all been killed
looking around him not seeing anything
not knowing he probably didn't know
which way to go anyway
you know i mean when you're seven and a
half years old and you don't stand very
tall
and you're in mud you probably look
around and think the whole world
everybody's dead he must have thought
that
i'm the only survivor here i remember
i tried to kill myself because i thought
it was the end of the world
i found a glass bottle and tried to stab
my stomach with the sharps
i couldn't feel it anymore because i had
too many wounds all over my body
then i saw somebody alive from afar i
threw the bottle shards away
and tried to keep myself alive i ate
anything that i could swallow
and drank raindrops
given the the scale of the devastation
you know he told us he told us the story
that he had seen
his family washed away and
after that um you know 20 days later
they hadn't come to try and look for him
or whatever else
so we just presumed that he was by
himself now
and we thought that he was going to be
an orphan
we decided because we we'd all had
children
that we should actually take him to save
the children
where he could be looked after and if he
had any family somewhere else in
indonesia
he would then be reunited with them
i think i put my hat on him keep the sun
off him and um
got him back into the truck and i uh we
had some ration packs
and i gave him some rations gave him
give him some water
couldn't communicate with that but we
just sort of gave him a bit of comfort
sat in between us
and then whipped him up to save the
children
martinez's story is quite simply
miraculous
he's clearly in need of medical
attention he's turned up this morning
so we took him there and there was a
lovely nurse from sierra leone
who basically made sure that he was warm
gave us a little bit of
understanding about again the sores and
his malnutrition
how much he was suffering he was still
shaking and
obviously very much in shock because he
suddenly had
you know human contact again you know
all this time
i'm filming throughout this so we can
kind of get the whole story
whilst he's been bathed save the
children in the background
are arranging for a car to take him to
hospital um
we went back to the house to start
editing and
we got a call from save the children
[Music]
because up until that point we thought
that he was going to be an orphan
save the children had tracked him down
in hours
along with his great-grandmother we then
sent one of the other cameramen who was
with us richie
to go and film the sun being reunited
with the father
both of whom had seen each other washed
away
but nothing could replace this hand it
is his father's
a hand he must have thought would never
touch him again
i cried when i finally met my father
i asked him about my mum and my sisters
[Music]
he didn't reply but cried and it made me
cry even harder
i was so sad when i realized i had lost
my mom and my sisters
but at the same time also grateful that
i was found alive and i still had my
father
we came across martinez as we filmed on
banda aceh beach
we gave him food he was eager to eat the
boy is just a day after the story had
gone out
our producer got a phone call from
london
and it was the portuguese fa and
basically said
they had seen him he was wearing the
portuguese
[Music]
and so they wanted to help him and his
family uh
i didn't actually realize that i was
wearing a portugal t-shirt
i was a fan of them and ronaldo and that
was why i insisted my dad to buy that
t-shirt for me
it was absolutely tremendous but again
it didn't stop there for martinez it
really didn't
his dream is to be a footballer but it
is a dream that may have perished on
these beaches
i was fortunate enough to go back to
bandura six months after
we met up with martinez and his father
in their new house the portuguese in
particular
not least of them cristiano ronaldo who
visited indonesia
took the young boy's story to their
hearts and the portuguese fa
they had found out that his favorite
player
was ronaldo meant
kills frail in his native tongue he told
an interviewer
that when he met martinez and reflected
on what he'd been through
he saw a brave beautiful and healthy boy
ronaldo and martinez spent time together
playing video games his
father tells us then he gave him one of
these and
whilst there we found out that he was
actually going to go and open
that season's league for the portuguese
fa
meeting ronaldo was like a dream
and it gave me motivation and
encouragement to stay alive
after the loss of my mum and my sisters
when martinez walked out holding
ronaldo's hand
[Applause]
[Music]
they gave them a bond promise recently
marturi
[Applause]
i don't think it was any coincidence
that
when it turned out martinez
actually was good at football that he
ended up
at sporting lisbon's uh academy
in portugal
[Music]
i want to be successful and i want my my
parents proud of me
he was there for a couple of years but
he got injured
and following that he moved back to
bandarache
and got married and we now wait
the next chapter of his life story
i don't think any of us
realized the significance of the jersey
it was phenomenal the impact that had
[Applause]
since the making of this documentary
martinez's wife has given birth to a
baby girl
the family remain in aceh indonesia
miracle boy was written and produced by
robert mulhern
recordings in indonesia by fera israfila
for more information on this story visit
skynews.com forward slash
storycast21 next time
follow that my name is raul mode a
chilling phone call
leads to one of this century's most
notorious manhunts
i'm not covering the line views have
passed with me for 20 years